I want to tell you a story about Bettina
Rodriguez Aguilera
she's a 59 year old Republican she's a
former Doral Florida Councilwoman and
she's now running for Congress in
Florida to replace the retiring Ileana
ros-lehtinen what's the big deal just
somebody who's running right well the
big deal is that miss Aguilera claims
that she was abducted by aliens onto
their spaceship as she tells it she was
seven years old at the time the aliens
were blond with big bodies now I don't
know if you're an alien and you're blond
does that mean you have hair that's
blond or your skin is the color of what
human blonde hair is I don't really know
two of the aliens were female one was
male they visited her when she was seven
years old abducted her onto their
spaceship and later communicated
telepathically with her a number of
times she claims that instead of a
normal sort of yoke or steering wheel
type device that quartz rocks are used
to control the alien spaceship she
learned a number of interesting facts
from the aliens including that there are
30,000 skulls that are different from
human skulls in a cave in the
Mediterranean island of Malta that the
energy center of the world is in Africa
and that the Coral Castle which is a
limestone tourist attraction in Florida
is actually an ancient Egyptian pyramid
so these claims are from a few years ago
once she started running and became I
guess more more prominent or her name
was back in the media picture people
went to her and said hey what about
these claims that you made years ago do
you stand by them and she basically
ducked the question by saying listen
lots of people have reported seeing UFOs
including Ronald Reagan which is of
course very different than the
suggestion that she saw the quartz
driven quartz controlled alien
spacecraft firsthand when she was seven
years old now this is an interesting
element to the story as well
miss Aguilera calls herself a Christian
and I'm not sure how that sort of plays
into it and I know that some people
don't like it when I say this this is
just an honest question I'm not
to be offensive how is aliens visited me
different from Jesus speaks to me or
Jesus died and was resurrected and went
to heaven after having been born to a
woman who never had sex I I'm not trying
to offend anyone but I'm actually
interested in an argument that tells me
how specific religious stories that have
no basis in reality whatsoever beyond
faith are different than aliens anally
probed me or whatever and but by the way
not that anal probing is a normal
subject on the David Pakman show but I'm
fascinated not by anal probing but by
the common thread that so many people
who report alien abductions report that
they there was anal probing and I
googled this a little bit and and
there's actually quite a bit written
about why that's a common trope in alien
abduction stories like why would an
alien species that comes from the far
reaches of the universe come to earth
abduct people and then anally probe them
like it has never made sense to me why
would they do that I've never seen a
good explanation for why that would be